Hi, I'm Steve Micah and I'm a Cubmaster with PAC 43 in Appalachia, New York.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Thanks, Clark. And now see you, Scoutmaster.
This is interesting. This just came on the wire from the Scouting Science Center
in Zern, Switzerland, where they have the Large Baden Collider.
This is just a study about the Tutankhamen effect.
I don't know if you're familiar with it or not.
The Tutankhamen effect states that people sleeping in a mummy bag experience urinary urgency.
Yes, that's what I said.
They experience this urgency in inverse proportion to the temperature
and the degree of difficulty in operating the bags. zipper up.
Sounds about right.
Hey, this is podcast number 348..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green.
For one reason or another, the first thing we do is look in the mailbag.
So let's take a look. Oh yes, There we are.
There's virtual mail in the virtual mailbag.
We heard from Matt Weiss, who's an assistant Scoutmaster of Troop 38 in New Berlin, Wisconsin,
who shared a really interesting idea with me.
One really great conservation service project you can do
is to go out and clear an area of invasive species of plants.
He said, instead of announcing to our Cub Scouts that we were going to go out
and clear garlic mustard, which is an invasive.
we announced that we were going to protect our parks from an alien invasion
and made posters with scary aliens.
I like that idea. Thanks, Matt.
Last week's podcast: we talked about Scouting's iterative process
and Bruce commented over on Facebook. great podcast this week.
I hope all of my program adults listen to it.
I hope so too, Bruce.
I heard from Laura Murkut, who is with Troop 139 in Sherman Oaks, California,
who got in touch to say I would like permission to print and use
the how to build campfire info graphic for our Scouts to use.
And Laura absolutely do that
And I really appreciate you asking. but anyone who's listening,
I am just so pleased when people find whatever I'm doing useful
and they want to use it to advance the cause of Scouting.
They want to share it with their Scouts, their parents,
their families, their district, whatever.
It's all good, Please do.
There's just two caveats to this.
One is is that you let people know where you found the information
And second, of course, is the sharing is in a non-commercial context.
That's all. Otherwise, share away.
Well, last Tuesday we had a live chat session
and we will most likely have one this Tuesday,
unless I have a summons for jury duty
And I will know if I have to report for it until later on today.
But usually what we do is we have a live chat session
over at ScoutMasterCGcom,
Usually Tuesday mornings around 8 am Eastern Standard Time.
Come and check in and say hello,
Like Adam Roth, who is a Cub Master with PAC 423,
and Steve Majka, who's a Cub Master and Weeblows Den Leader
in the Baden Powell Council in upstate New York did.
Both Steve and Adam checked in last week for the first time
And I may have missed a couple of people there.
Boy, we had a crowd on last week.
Live chat Tuesday mornings around 8 am.
If I'm not on jury duty tomorrow, come to ScoutMasterCGcom,
Sign in, join us.
We talk about serious stuff and not so serious stuff.
you know how it goes.
Before I go any further, I want to pause here
to thank all the folks who make ScoutMasterCGcom possible.
There's two ways to do this.
You can be a backer or you can be a subscriber through Patreon.
If you go to ScoutMasterCGcom-
just about any page on the website-
look up on the right-hand top
and you'll see links on how to make this happen,
how to become a backer or a patron,
But I want to thank Timothy Haberman and James Casper,
who both have added their names
to the list of ScoutMasterCGcom backers
since our last podcast,
And thanks to everyone who supports the blog
and the podcast through Patreon,
including Walter Scott Sweitzer,
who became a patron subscriber since our last podcast.
If you're interested in supporting what we're doing here,
go ahead this week, figure out which option
is going to work best for you
And I will thank you personally during next week's podcast.
Well, let's see,
I think we got everything taken care of there
And I have some email questions to answer.
So let's get started, shall we?
I know, deep down, you can't,
I cannot help but wonder
why you do the things you do.
I hope you will remember
that it's our plight to do
cause. I am a Sasquatch
and I live among the trees
and I am proud to be a Sasquatch.
I live in peace and harmony,
in harmony,
in harmony.
email, that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Okay, I have one, two, three email questions to answer this week
and, because of the extraordinary sensitivity
of the subject matter,
each will remain anonymous.
Here is the first one.
Our scout master says it's his job
to decide who goes to national youth leadership training each year
from the troop
and which of the training courses they should go to.
Our committee says they decide who goes
and where they can go,
since they're the ones that cover the costs for the scouts attending.
Do you know of any official materials
that can help us figure out who decides
who goes to the training,
where they go and who pays?
Well, probably not going to be able to help you
find anything that specific in policy,
but we can certainly talk about some generalities
that may help inform the situation
And just to broaden the scope of the whole thing.
you know, when decisions like this
devolve into a turf battle between adults,
it indicates that something's kind of out of whack
in their basic understanding and attitudes.
We're not commanding officers or bosses
and scouts aren't soldiers or employees
that we order around.
So if a scout wants to go to national youth leadership training
and they come to me and they say,
hey, yeah, I want to do this training,
I would say, well, more power to you.
Do you know where you're going? and everything like that.
Yep, Yep, Okay, Great, Go for it,
And I suppose I could recommend a course.
It's really none of my business,
And if you were fortunate enough to be in an area
that had several choices of courses, locations and times,
and they asked me to recommend one.
I suppose I could,
And whether or not they took my recommendation on that
is totally up to them, and their parents
doesn't really make a difference to me
Now, because the troop is paying for the course.
it would seem to me, in the event of difference of opinion
the committee would take precedence over the scout master,
because that's just the way troops are ran.
just the committee chair can appoint or remove a scout master
as they see fit, with the consent
of the chartered organization representative.
So if we want to have a turf war,
the committee chair is going to win.
Let's not have a turf war, because turf war
always result in a negative effect on scouts
and on the program as a whole.
Boy, it just saps everybody's energy right away from them.
So resolving this particular question
probably goes a little deeper than who's in charge
or who gets to decide what.
I think there's just like a basic misunderstanding
of what scouting is about.
I'm not really interested in that level of control,
to tell you the truth.
So this second email begins this way:
My son was a Cub Scout.
I helped as a den leader
and I followed him into the Boy Scout troop
and became an assistant scout master.
My son's moving along.
He's earned first class. after a couple of years
I didn't realize how much I had missed scouting.
I was a scout myself
and I think I'll likely stay on doing this work.
I would even say that I would stay on with this troop
after he ages out.
That's how much I enjoy being a volunteer.
We're a small troop right now, but we're growing.
and here's my question:
As much as my son and I enjoy it,
our troop is as disorganized as one can be.
The scout master and his assistants
have been around for a couple of decades,
yet they seem to do everything by the seat of their pants.
The adults do create an annual schedule,
but many times the locations of the trips
aren't finalized as late as a week or two
before the trip,
and this kind of thing drives me crazy.
The troop is definitely not youth led
and I really didn't realize this
until I went to training to be an assistant scout master.
The scout master makes all the patrols,
assigns the patrol leaders
and even created the patrol names.
The scouts are young,
so there's no senior patrol leader.
I suspect the scout master would probably
choose who was senior patrol leader
if we did have one.
Make no mistake,
the scout master and the other
scouters involved with the troop are good men.
They're easy to get along with,
They care for the scouts.
They just prefer to lead the troop themselves.
I've suggested changes before.
They seem to be willing to listen,
but I sense they're not willing to actually
implement any significant changes.
We anticipate a large group of weevilos joining soon,
so I'm interested in at least discussing changes
that would be more faithful to the patrol method.
How do you think I should approach the scout master with this,
since it would be a significant change?
If they sounded agreeable, what would we do next?
I've listened to several podcasts about this,
but they're more conceptual than directive.
I was hoping for more detail,
Kind of like an order of events.
Well, first, I'm glad you're finding the podcast useful
and I'm glad you got in touch with me,
because what's happened to you
has happened to a lot of assistant scout masters
who've sent me similar questions.
You've run across this guy online
who has a podcast and a particular vision of scouting
that doesn't correspond to what you see in your troop
and you want to change things around.
So my standard advice when I get a question like this
is I usually tell people to find another troop
that more closely corresponds to what they'd like to have
for their son. but that doesn't seem to be an option here,
and I understand. my second piece of advice-
I don't think is an option here either,
which is, you know, start a troop.
If you can't find a troop that isn't operating
the way that you think it ought to operate,
well, look into starting one,
and that's never really a very popular option.
So if neither of these things appeal to you,
the next thing I have to do is ask you
why you want to change things
Now. there's no indication that any young people
are actually being harmed by the adults involved,
no undercurrent of general dissatisfaction
or, and perhaps more importantly,
a shared notion that things need changing.
Now you'd note that things aren't quite as organized
as you like, and I gotta tell you
that's not unusual. besides, if you change things around,
you'll be trading one form of frustrating
disorganization for another.
There is no such thing as frustration. free scouting-
You may quote me
So from what you've told me about your,
the troop and your experiences-
is: the troop is having regular meetings,
they're going camping and scouts are advancing,
so it's functioning and serving the interests
of scouts at least in some measure correct.
Obviously, if an adult does all the leading,
it denies a number of opportunities to the scouts.
but you know this is far more common
than youth led troops, at least in my experience.
While the adult led model is not optimal,
it does not do objective harm,
It just denies scouts are more expansive
and I guess some would say authentic scouting experience.
I guess if I wanted to be really hard-nosed I would say that
you know, without the patrol method in operating
it's not really scouting.
but the real heart of the matter here is
the single most important issue
is, as an assistant scout master,
you're not in a position to lead a series of changes
and I'm going to emphasize that.
I'm going to repeat it: as an assistant scout master,
you're really not in a position
to implement a series of changes. you've come into this,
you've looked at it, you go: I'm not really satisfied
with the way things are going.
I want to change everything around. well, that's kind of like
saying: give me the wheel, I want to drive the car
when you're in the backseat,
Since I'm talking with somebody who's working within the BSA.
the way the BSA defines things
is the troops committee chair is more or less
the decision maker and director,
but in reality, most of the- a lot of the times,
the scout master has pretty broad authority,
makes all the decisions and the committee chair
is more in the background.
so the scout master is usually going to be the person who
decides whether they're going to make changes or not.
and absent a shared notion that change is needed
and a shared vision of what the changes ought to be,
I don't see a whole lot of potential for change
in this or any other situation.
but nevertheless,
nothing ventured, nothing gained right, go ahead,
make some suggestions, have a discussion with the scout master,
see what kind of, see what kind of headway you can make.
I don't understand any of the personal dynamics involved
and I can't really effectively advise you
on how those suggestions should be made.
but if, but, if the scout master is a receptive person
and they're easy to get along with.
you know, if I were just doing it myself,
I'd probably just tell him what I was thinking.
I'm not a particularly subtle person.
that's the way I would handle it.
I would just say: you know, I went to training.
they talk about this patrol method.
I'd like to discuss that with you
and I wonder if you've ever thought about making some changes
to bring things more in line with the patrol method.
so the only other open issue is: okay,
so let's say that you go to the scout master
or the committee chair or whoever
and you make some suggestions about changes
and they say, yeah, great, let's do that.
what do you do next?
and I'm often asked what kind of
you know concrete steps you should take
to change from being adult led
to being youth led,
and I don't know. I've never really been able to come up
with a step-by-step list,
although I've tried.
but of course, the crucial first thing
that would have to happen
is all the adults involved have to be on the same page.
they have to agree what this is going to look like.
after that, there's really no secret formula.
you talk to your scouts,
you tell them what the changes are going to be,
you stop doing things one way
and you start doing things another way,
and scouts are reasonably flexible
with this kind of thing.
but you know you're going to go through
a longish period of transition
before you get to the point where you have
exchanged one set of frustrations for another one-
and you know I do get this kind of question
on a fairly regular basis.
I am in a troop.
I'm not happy with the way it's going.
I would like to change things
to the way you say they should be going,
because you sound very smart.
if you're not in a position
in the organizational structure of a troop
to implement changes like this,
suggesting them to those that are in those positions
is one way to go.
but you have to realize
you could just end up being very frustrated
about the whole thing
because your suggestions may fall on deaf ears.
that's why I say: you know,
either find a troop
that corresponds more closely
to the way you think things
ought to be done
or start one yourself,
because the chance your frustrations
are going to go away
because of some suggestions that you make,
I don't know-
doesn't seem to be like
a high probability strategy to me.
so this last email answer
is actually an answer to an email question,
but there's no real reason to read the whole email.
here's the story
I heard from a scout master who said
that they were kind of frustrated.
they're relatively new to the work
and they were encountering the usual things
that we encounter:
parents who were perhaps
used to being a little over involved in things,
a troop that wasn't functioning as he wanted.
you know
the the kind of thing that we pretty much
live with all the time.
they sent me a very long email.
they had written to the troops families,
kind of laying things out
in a once for all kind of fashion,
making some big statements,
and- and
you know what I mean. right,
the most of us have written,
have written that email
at least once before.
they wanted me to review the email,
comment on how it could be improved.
and here is
the way that I replied.
since you asked,
I'm going to be very plain and direct.
don't mistake this for criticism.
it's because it's intended
in the best spirit possible.
I would never suggest sending an email
like this.
it has much more potential
for harm than good.
so whoever's on your side
in these issues
will look it over
and soon forget what you've said.
the opposition
will find plenty of leverage
to argue about what you've written.
they'll reread and dissect it
and discuss it amongst themselves,
and the neutral faction
will not read it very much at all.
they may scan it a little bit
and you're going to find that
all three of those reactions,
rather than helping you
sort out, your frustrations
are just going to be more frustrating.
so
look,
in my experience,
parents do not read things like this.
they don't really read things like
you know- a troop policy manual-
if you have one
and you don't really want to have one-
they don't really read
much of anything
in order to attempt to understand
what is going on.
that's not necessarily a criticism,
that's just an observation
based on my experience.
a lot of times parents are not all
that interested in delving down
into the specifics of stuff like that,
but when something happens
that challenges what they assume
ought to happen,
that's when they start to get vocal
and then you explain
why you're doing what you're doing
and you have to deal with these issues
over and over and over again
individually,
one parent at a time,
because often husbands and wives
don't even end up discussing
what you have told one or another.
so this never goes away.
it's a feature of our work.
it's not a flaw
that can be fixed by
writing email
or putting out a troop policy manual
or having extensive
introductory meetings.
this is just one of the costs
of doing business as a scouter.
this never goes away,
never, ever.
now, that's not to say that
you shouldn't make sure to offer
information to families
so that they can understand things.
all I'm saying is
I wouldn't look at the offer
of that information
as a high percentage solution
to solving your frustrations.
now, if you do want some advice
on how to get things
more energized and rolling
in a better direction,
I'll repeat what I said
in an earlier email answer.
the way troops are constituted
in the in the BSA,
the committee chair
is the central decision maker
bound to carry out the policies
and procedures of the BSA
that shape the program.
this is not a democratic process.
it's not subject to the opinion
of parents or other volunteers,
and I would never introduce
the idea that it is.
we don't sit down and litigate
the elements of the program.
they're presented to us.
we carry them out.
and I'm not saying that
scouting is autocratic
because it is a team sport.
it's just, like
Baden Powell said,
a jolly game, right,
and that depends on
family scouts and scouts
working together
in a collaborative process.
when people understand their roles
in that process
or their positions on the team
that plays this jolly game,
then things get energized.
so if I were in your shoes
and I felt like things weren't going
quite according to plan
and I was frustrated.
I would sit down
with my committee chair
and assure that you both have
each other's unquestioning support
and shared understanding
of how things move forward.
if you can't achieve
this kind of understanding,
well, reconsider.
if this is a group of people
you want to continue to work with,
if you can arrive
at a good working agreement
with your committee chair,
then move on.
when someone challenges
what you're doing,
tell them the basis of your actions,
ask them to follow your lead.
you and the committee chair
are the leader
of the other adult volunteers.
they take direction from you,
not the other way around.
so when there's a decision
to be made,
they're looking for your leadership.
although it is a collaborative process,
although
we do our best to seek consensus,
there has to be people
who make decisions
and who are leading
the other adult volunteers.
so the author of that email
got back to me and said:
I value your honesty
and straightforward advice.
I'm going to start writing
letters like this
more often
and keep them to myself.
it was very cathartic
and it helped me sort out
my thoughts and frustrations.
well, I would encourage
everyone to do that.
write as much as you want
about why you're doing
what you're doing
and the frustrations
that you encounter.
write them as a letter to yourself
that
no one will ever see.
it is a useful cathartic
as well as a way to refine
your approach
and to deal with the common
frustrations that we all deal with.
I started doing that
a long, long time ago
and then I started the blog,
and the rest is history, I suppose,
is what they say right.
this scouter
was dealing with
frustrations he was having
with parents,
misunderstanding
or being a little over involved
in what was going on.
so now this is going to
sound kind of cranky,
but I think it's reasonably accurate.
95% of the problems
we encounter as scouts
are going to originate
with our scouts families,
their parents specifically,
the 5% of the problems
that we have that originate
with scouts
are usually exacerbated
by the involvement of their parents.
scouts themselves
are not all that hard to work with.
usually you can solve things
with scouts,
but parents
it's a little more difficult.
now, just in case that sounds bitter
or cynical,
I want to explain that it isn't.
it's just the reality of working
with young people.
it's been that way
since the whole thing started.
it will continue to be that way
for the foreseeable future.
you can go back
as far as you want
in scouting literature
anywhere at any time,
and you're going to find
that people encounter
these same frustrations.
the world isn't going to hell in a handbasket.
there's not been this massive sea change
about the attitudes that parents have
when it comes to volunteers
who are dealing with their children.
this is just the way things have been
and the way that they will continue to be.
it's an important part
of your work as a scouter.
the real problem seems to be
we don't prepare our volunteers
to work with families
as well as we prepare them
to work with scouts.
you know we do a pretty good job
of familiarizing people
with the policies and procedures
of the organization,
the important points of the goals
and the methods of scouting
and a lot of logistical information,
but we usually leave the development
of the soft skills
that are needed to deal with
the frustrations that you're going to have
in dealing with scouts families.
we kind of leave that up to you.
so i want to hear about your general
or specific challenges
when it comes to working with
scouts, families and parents,
what you've learned
or what you need help with,
and you can get in touch with me.
it's very easy to do
and i'm going to tell you
how to do that in just a moment.
well, thanks for listening
to this 348th edition
of the scoutmaster podcast.
here's how to keep in touch.
you'll find all tons of articles
and all the past editions
of the podcast at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there,
you can subscribe to receive
updates by email.
you can join us
in the vast panorama of social media.
there are over 16,000 folks
who like scoutmaster blog on facebook.
we have a chorus of tweeters on twitter.
we have a bunch of pinners on pinterest.
we are there on video at youtube.
but if you can't face facebook
and twitter makes you better,
you have no interest in pinterest
and don't put the you in youtube.
don't worry, old timer,
you can just zoom in to the late 1990s
and fire off a good old-fashioned email.
i'm always available at
clark at scoutmastercgcom.
that's c, l, a, r, k, e at
scoutmastercgcom
if all else fails.
the next time you're out camping,
gather all your fellow scouters
around a magic mirror
and repeat scoutmastercg three times
in unison
and i'll appear there to answer
all your questions,
solve all your problems.
well, by now it should be abundantly
clear that the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of anyone in particular
other than myself.
no, i am not indoor store sponsored
by any scouting organization,
including the Boy Scouts of America.
this is just my way of reaching out
to lend a hand to my fellow scouters
and having a little bit of fun.
and speaking of fun,
here he is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you
and good camping.
well, thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.
you.